under the knife Salaam alaikum peace be
with you another episode where a lie
we're taking a deep breath because God
Almighty the Creator has given us
disability to breathe for the heart to
pump he's given us so many favours that
you cannot enumerate all the blessings
that he's given us Shimon would be
thankful and grateful so when you've
acknowledged is there's nothing worthy
of worship except the one who created
creation I'm gonna worship the Creator
and not his creation and then you have
to prove it by action and one of the
first actions after you submitted in
this testimony there's nothing worthy of
worship Allah the Creator that happens
in Earth how many is the last and final
messenger the same way if you were
living different jesus's time you accept
him as a mighty messenger no where did
he ever claim say propagate that he was
God's Son of God none of these things he
was calling people to worship God so
after that they called the people to
pray to God to establish the five daily
prayers in their lives as Muslims so can
you be a Muslim can you be one who
submitted to the will of God if you're
not connected to God through the five
daily prayers we're going to have our
next guest answer this question we come
back door anyway
this is the thesis but angels
so I'm making peace be with you are they
cancel our to LA how are you very good
Sheikh Nasser how's it going it's going
real good good to have you on the show
my pleasure
got a nice grip there that's how we roll
that's how full master it's it's it's
the southern Texas grip yeah thank you
for it's my pleasure
really admired Dean show and your work
for a very long time
my younger brother Abdullah is a huge
fan of the show and watches it all the
time and you know I I had a little story
to share with you please go ahead a
couple of summers ago three summers ago
I visited Vermont and there's one much
in the whole state of Vermont the Juma
congregation the Friday sermon the
Friday prayer is probably about 70
people at the most really small
community and so I went out there to
give some lectures do some programs I
met a young man an Albanian young man
and he was he was really struggling a
lot of challenges they had literally
seen their own father killed before
their own eyes him and his two older
brothers and they came here they were
basically living here on their own
working like you know some type of a
nightshift like a janitor job somewhere
just trying to get by and unfortunately
they'd fallen into a lot of bad stuff
they were drinking and partying and
gambling and doing all this stuff and
the youngest brother who's probably you
know 18 years old 19 years old right out
of high school he said that one day he
was searching for something
I think on YouTube you are searching for
something about music and you must have
done an episode about something in
regard so related to music and it showed
up in some of the related videos
clicked it and started watching it and
he said he got hooked he said he did not
leave the computer for like two days he
just kept coming back kept coming back
and just watching this he said he saw
every single episode that you had ever
recorded and he said it changed his life
and I didn't even know you back then he
introduced me to didn't show but he just
said do you know brother Eddie do you
know brother Eddie I said I don't know
brother Eddie and he showed me the show
and you know I just wanted to let you
know that there's hopefully insha'Allah
he'll watch this episode as well but
there's lots of people out there like
that that I've really benefited so may
Allah bless you and reward you and
accept this blessed effort under the law
all praises to the creator of the
heavens and earth who's given us this
ability to be here and inshallah God
willing inshallah God willing that the
creator of the heavens in her except
this robot I mean I mean so I'll feel
some of the silence you know you you
interview everybody I know you've made a
movie there's a movie there's I have yet
to get the pleasure to watch it and
shall I intend to
God willing but so I want to watch it
but I've you know I don't know if the
local Dallas folks have gotten to and
some of the folks in my community have
gotten to know enough about you yet so
from I hear on really reliable sources
that you're pretty nasty when a like if
you get in the ring with brother Eddie
you could tear you out pretty bad that's
that's what I hear
masha'Allah alhamdulillah creator of the
herb has given me disability that you
know I've excelled in this sport Gracey
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu that's right before
that you know going through life you
know basically blinded by the delights
and the tantalize ations of this life
you know and I got to experience that
life of the days of ignorance and then
you taste the sweetness of a man you
taste the sweetness of Islam Hollinger
exactly so I investigated many of the
different ways of lives that were out
there but Islam provided the proof and
the evidence
that it was the true from the creator of
the heavens there right after that I
found out me the crater he wants to be
worshipped alone no partners next to him
worshiping God alone without any
associations and then you established a
prayer I got hooked up with that it's
and I didn't leave that hundred losses
that time I have not missed it's a lot
so we want to help those who are out
there who might not know they say you
know I'm a Muslim but they didn't know
they have to pray after the show we
don't want anyone to have an excuse on
why they're not prostrating and thanking
the one who gave us so many of these
blushes you specializes in this topic is
this right there's what one that you
love talking about yeah I've traveled
around the country for the last three
years teaching a class of course a
workshop where I go through not only how
we pray but why we pray and what are we
saying when we're praying it's been a
real pleasure I've probably interacted
with close to about you know seven eight
thousand people all across the country
just talking about this topic of prayer
and it's it's really interesting one of
the things that you just said you know
when you were searching for truth and
you said that you know of course Islam
was was a no brainer it was automatic
you knew Islam was meant for you when
you came across it one of the things
about the prayer in Islam that makes
Islam so beautiful so unique it makes
the prayer such an important part of our
faith in our religion is that it adds
the practicality to our faith it becomes
something practical it's not just
theoretical but it's practical it's
implemented on a daily basis it's
something you interact with it's
something that you you you you sink
you know you roll up your sleeves and
you you just dig into and you feel it so
it's not just something you talk about
do you talk about or you think about but
it's something you do and and that a lot
of times is something that's really
really life-changing for a lot of people
because when we talk about when people
try to figure out the purpose of life
and why they exist there's a lot of
fancy talk and there's a lot of
philosophical you know exchange of ideas
but Aslam brings a practicality through
the pray
what I always tell people is the our
five times daily prayer is faith
manifest its faith manifest its
manifesting itself so you say this is
what I believe but you're showing that
that's what you believe and and you hit
the nail on the head when when you say
that you know the question a lot of
times that comes out well you know can
you be Muslim and not pray right that's
a common question yes can you be Muslim
and not pray what kind of a Muslim would
not pray I think that the dialogue needs
to change we need to be asking the
question to make people think in this
matter why don't you want to pray yes
yes why don't you want to pray you
mentioned about blessings I mean think
about all the blessings that we have of
Allah how blessed we are by Allah and
and I mean just take any one blessing
for instance any one blessing random the
ability to see one unbelievable blessing
of Allah I mean I wouldn't know what the
sky looked like what the trees looked
like I would have never seen the faces
of my beautiful children if I didn't
have the ability to see now if I realize
how truly blessed I am you know
gratitude it motivates you to do
something about it so brother Eddie if
you know I was in some really hard times
I lost my job I lost my house I lost
everything and you helped me out and
Allah praise be to God you helped me out
you rolled up you gave me some money you
gave me some cash you gave me a place to
stay you let me borrow your car you
found me a job and everything you hook
me up if you call me a year later asking
for a little favor hey I'm at the
airport I need a ride to my house or
something before you even finish asking
the question I'm there don't go nowhere
I'm coming absolutely yeah I'm on my way
and when I come to pick you up if you
try to thank me I'll be offended don't
don't say thank you to me thank you for
giving me the
to do something for you and if you try
to give me some gas money when we reach
your house like here you go here's a
little something since you went to all
this trouble I'd be insulted like no man
and for everything you did for me you I
finally got a little opportunity do
something for you now the human being
Muslim non-muslim alike has just got to
take a minute of their time to sit down
and think about how truly blessed they
are by God how many the minute in light
just stop just texting right now the
material things I stop and think that's
it that's it like where we're about to
go to a commercial break during that
commercial break everybody watching I
want you to literally just sit down for
that 30-second 60 seconds whatever the
commercial break is and I want you to
close your eyes remove the distractions
and just think about how blessed you are
count your blessings
and then ask yourself the question what
are you willing to do to thank him for
giving you all of that that's right you
got your homework we'll be right back
think about it
Aladin show no problem you can take my
daughter to dinner you and my daughter
and me it's just ideas and he created us
to have a good time we should have a
good time when it was out wise though
Islam is the fastest growing religion in
the world and most of the converts are
women not men they see that the rules of
Islam
instead of constraining it the rule set
them free
hunger
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about the second pillar of Islam
Islam has been there since time
immemorial first man Adam did Islam
absolutely Moses did it's not absolutely
Jesus did it's live and Muhammad peace
be upon him he's the final messenger
absolutely taught and brought Islam
submission to the will of God mm-hmm and
after that you agree which in your very
nature that I want to worship the
Creator not his creation now the best of
examples are the prophets and Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he's teaching
us how to get close to God right
absolutely so some people say well why
does God want me to this is one argument
that some people let's say will say why
don't you pray why does God need my
prayer I'm busy at work I got so much
work to do how you know why does God
need this from me and that's that's a
really really valid question because
somebody who's trying to wrap their head
around it would have that question again
I'm gonna flip the question around let's
not ask ourselves whether God needs our
prayers or not because we know he
doesn't but let's ask the question
whether we need to pray to God or not I
mean you know I often give this example
when trying to explain to people the
practical role of prayer in their
everyday lives
you know we have these unbelievably
awesome devices these smart phones but
they're you guys you got a smartphone
iPhone nothing Rays iPad
oh nice okay there you go close enough
so these little cool devices you know
iPhone Android iPad all these great
devices they're unbelievable yes oh man
they do everything you know that you can
surf the web you can check your email
book of flights play video games you
know and they make phone calls too right
so they do everything and anything
there's one problem with these devices
anyone regardless of what brand or model
of device they have they all have one
Universal complaint everybody who uses
these devices let's see if you can guess
what is what is it battery life hmm
because they're so awesome because
they're so multifunctional because
they're doing 18 things at the same time
battery runs out like this need to
recharge all the time all the time
that's right
like I'll talk about an iPhone because I
have an iPhone like iPhone users they
Chargers everywhere they have a charger
by their bed they have a charger in the
kitchen they have a charger in the
bathroom sucker love they have a
bathroom a truck they have a charger in
be in their car you know I'm pretty sure
sisters walking around with Chargers in
their purse
I got a charger in my backpack Chargers
everywhere and so you got to always keep
charging you got to keep recharging
it's very multifunctional it's a really
awesome device thing and do a lot it's
awesome but it's just the charge runs
out so you got a recharge well the human
being is the best of God's creation he's
amazing this human being is an amazing
creation capable of so much I mean look
at the earth look at the world that we
live in but there's a problem that
battery runs out that that capacity
Withers I was actually talking to a
couple of physicians yesterday one of
them who's a psychiatrist and he was
kind of talking about some research
about willpower and you know talking
about mental fatigue and things like
that and he was actually commenting on
the same thing that you know if if
mentally you become fatigued then the
entire body everything else that you're
capable of emotional mental fatigue
leads can lead to a big strong healthy
human being becoming completely
worthless
so that emotional mental fatigue
spiritual fatigue and that's life I mean
look at the terms that we got you know
road rage frustrated nervous anxious
angry upset tired exhausted fatigued
there's wear and tear we go to work it's
the grind we're driving home from work
it's a grind taking care of the kids at
home it's a grind so the human being
keeps wearing down wearing down wearing
down well then what's our charge where
can i plug in to get my read my recharge
charge my battery backup and that's our
prayer that's the prayer that's the
prayer because when we pray see that's
the thing I think we all missed the boat
on when we stand up and we pray we're
talking to Allah and the most remarkable
thing to think that personally for me
changed my life
was that we have a prophetic tradition
is actually called a sacred tradition
hadith Qudsi where the Prophet tells us
what God has said in those exact words
and he tells us that when the slave when
the human being the creation stands up
and prays to the Creator and you recite
surah fatiha the first opening chapter
of the Quran the holy text at that time
for every verse that we read God
responds to every single verse so it not
only is it that we are talking to God
when we pray but he's responding back to
us we're having a conversation with God
when we pray you know you know if you're
having a tough day you know everyone's
got somebody in their life you talk to
when you're having a tough day you know
I'll talk to my wife it's this kind of
unloading kind of helps me deal with
what's going on imagine talking to God
at a minimum of five times a day minimum
minimum of five times a day like your
burdens are gone what else do you have
to worry about it's it's the most
unbelievable feeling mm-hmm and so your
question was why does God need me to
pray to Him now I know I need to pray to
God I need this prayer this prayer is a
gift it's not a burden it's not an
obligation it's not you know something
that's forced on me it's a gift a
treasure and an opportunity and and I
know that a lot of the audience that
watches the Deen show and I want to
emphasize one thing about the prayer the
prayer how we pray it you know we with
the timings are very specific that we
pray five times a day but even the
format of how we pray you know somebody
who's watching this video maybe they
seen a Muslim praying somewhere and they
see them kind of like doing these
awkward movements and putting their head
on the ground and all these different
things and could try and figure out
what's going on something remarkable
that our tradition teaches us the sacred
tradition that was given to all the
prophets all the messengers teaches us
that the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him he prayed but the
Quran is telling us that Jesus
peace be upon him he also prayed in
Chapter number nineteen suna 19 sort of
Maryam that's named after his mother
Mary it actually says well Osan IBAs
salat he was a Katia madam Maya My Lord
has commanded me to pray as long as I'm
alive Ishmael the son of Abraham peace
be upon them prophet of God he prayed
not only would he pray but the narration
the diverse actually says what kinda
Yahoo I'll be Sola not only would he
pray he would tell his family to pray
with him he tell his family to pray with
him it talks about Abraham prank it
talks about Mary the mother of Jesus
being told by God to pray so every
single prophet from the beginning of
time has prayed so when we pray we're
following in the footsteps of not only
our beloved prophet but in the footsteps
of all the prophets all the prophets
every single the same tradition every
single one Jesus fell on his face and
prayed Moses Abraham it allows the fun
of us or centum a kind of problem Ahamed
absolutely we're not making up anything
new nothing this is the original way
that's it is the highway that leaves the
pit leads to paradise absolutely I know
that for myself before we go to break
when I was submitting to the creator and
all the wonderful things that he wants
us to do and I started to pray I know
that some of the things weren't right I
know I was in places I shouldn't have
been this was in the beginning stages
but I was still connected I leave and go
in the car to pray when the time was to
pray go back in a place I shouldn't be
but the more I was connected with the
crater the more it established that
consciousness of God of a law in my life
and I started to slowly clean up it was
like a medicine you were taking and
little by little all these bad habits
the more you started to think of a law
the more you started to remember him
through the prayer you didn't like a lot
of these places these things that you
were doing you start to live a good
organic life and I'll tell you something
else because that's beautiful what you
just told us you don't why because that
prayer can be your anchor
so a storm came in your life and it
drifted your boat a little bit off the
dock but your anchor was there holding
you back and when the storm settled it
brought you back home yeah yeah
hamdullah I'm love we're gonna take a
break and be right back with more we're
talking about the prayer connecting with
the Creator through the player get
plugged in with the salat with the
prayer be right back and if we're gonna
worship something I figured I might as
well worship the Creator instead of any
of the creations now in upon
investigating the religions I remember
finding out the meaning of what Islam is
what Muslim is those who surrender their
self to God is a Muslim
those who cemento submit to God God's
will die see Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator
back here on the D show and we're
discussing the second pillar of Islam
first is really all of Islam is really
easy to understand it's clear it's
nothing esoteric where it takes you know
a lot of mental gymnastics to make it
fit only one God and a worship Him alone
I'm gonna be the messenger that God sent
her Muhammad is the last and the prayer
we're not gonna go too far into the
charity and into the fasting and then
the Hajj five pillars so we want people
to get hooked up with the second pillar
because people come to you I'm sure and
their lives are upside down yep and then
you ask them I'm sure you know do you
pray five times a day the guys like or
the girls like no that's your answer
right absolutely absolutely
I don't want a simpler over like
simplify people's issues and or insult
anyone who might have any problems but
you know we can only give an answer that
was given to us by God in his messenger
peace and blessings be upon him so and
really the solution is right there it's
right there in front of us that if you
can just connect yourself back to God
you know there's a beautiful verse in
the Quran that says well man you mean
Bellavia the culpa when somebody truly
believes in God when somebody
reestablishes their faith that
relationship with God then he guides the
rest of the way for them he'll guide his
heart he'll guide their heart so if we
can just reestablish our connection to
Allah we can just start talking to him
on a daily basis we can talk to him
morning and evening he'll lead us the
rest of the way there we'll find our way
home and and you know something really
interesting an issue that a lot of
people have lost their way in regards to
in a Muslim community non-muslim
community all across the world today
especially I can talk about America this
where I'm from so
in America this is a really big issue
and that's the issue of the home and the
family
you know people's homes and families
falling apart the family unit the family
structures is falling apart at the seams
and there's something beautiful in the
practice in the tradition of our prophet
peace and blessings be upon him when he
first started preaching and teaching the
religion the first one to accept a faith
was his beloved wife Khadija may God be
pleased with her the second person to
accept the faith was actually his very
very younger cousin who was actually
living with him at the time his name was
Ali may Allah be pleased with him and so
it's kind of like a family as a
household and they've all embraced the
faith you know what the first activity
was that they would do together they
would pray together they would pray they
would pray together
that's deep they would pray together we
got problems I go around the country
teaching a workshop happiness in the
home everywhere I go and one of the main
things I tell people you want to fix
your family she's gonna fix the home
issues you want to solidify your home
base you know one of the best outlets
you have it's kind of like you know I
don't want to it is kind of a negative
example but killing two birds with one
stone they know killing going on over
here but that to take care of two things
at one time to take care of two things
at one time prayers out blessing when
you stand up and you pray not only are
you reestablishing your connection with
God Almighty but if you stood up and you
prayed with your family with your wife
with your kids you reestablished your
connection with your family and as a
family together y'all realest AB lished
y'all's connection with God Almighty
that's deep before we come to an end we
see that from the authentic text there
is so much hope given encouragement
through the prayer you're connecting
with the Creator your sins are being
absolved from prayer to prayer to the
gym on to the Jamaa and you'll see
there's hope I made a mistake I run to
the prayer I need to call upon the one
who hears all sees all I go to the
prayer absolutely now aren't there
consequences where God Almighty
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
in the Veda word of God and the
Thunderer hadith isn't it true that now
you know the Prophet peace be upon him
he told us that what's the first thing
that a person will be accountable for on
the day of judgement he said it's the
prayer and then he told us something
really interesting that the first thing
we'll be asked about is the prayer and
if that works out if now goes smooth
everything else will go smooth and if
that doesn't work out bankrupt we don't
because it's a foundation yeah so you
build a beautiful building on a faulty
foundation and it falls you only have
yourself to blame
last 30 seconds what do you got to tell
him now for those who they want to
submit they said look I want to get
cleaned up before I pray I don't feel
like I'm worthy enough to pray we have
all these excuses so what advice do you
have for the advice that I have is take
it out of being a ritual and make it a
spiritual experience experience a prayer
don't let it just be a ritual don't just
go through the motions read what you
have to read make it an experience in
order to make it an experience you might
have to put in a little bit of time a
little bit of effort but under read and
understand and educate yourself about
what you're saying and what you read in
your prayer what does that mean and
internalize the meaning of that and then
stand up and think about what you're
reading what you're saying to God and
engage in that conversation with Allah
with God and it'll change your life
thank you very much my pleasure I got
all my the credit rewards you oh yeah
and again thank you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
and don't it doesn't matter how
spiritually dirty you are how many sins
you've committed and you feel like how
can i how can i how can i pray go ahead
and make the will do go ahead and clean
yourself up and go ahead because when
you make the prayer you get spiritually
cleaned up that's what changes your life
for the better when you get connected
with a crater and the sins start to
absolve and start to go away through the
prayer you get plugged in and you get
hooked up with God Almighty through the
prayer make the prayer when we finish
this show go ahead and pray to God ask
God for forgiveness the one who Jesus
Moses Abraham
and the last and final messenger sent to
mankind they all pray to the one God not
to the creation of God but to the one
create tour and give us a call 1 800 662
Islam operators are standing by if you
want to accept this beautiful way of
life where you'd like to get the
verbatim words we got the Quran anytime
we're here give us a call we'll see you
next time peace be unto you